Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google.
Today is my pleasure to
welcome director Danny Boyle.
Hello.
We're here for trainspotting
t two trainspotting. Yes.
Uh, and it's 21 years later.
So you guys have a crack at writing
SQL awhile back. And you know,
you'd mentioned that it didn't quite
work and so you guys came back and
revisited what was it between the,
that version and the one
you've just written that
really was like the difference
between like, this is actually a
movie we want to make. I think you was
that we were very,
um,
I'm sure that person was fine,
but we,
there was no reason to make it other
than the fact that urban had published a
novel and then it felt
like a commercially, you
know, a debt thing to do.
And when you read it, you just feel,
you just felt wretched. And I think,
I think the reason for that
was that you realize that, um,
if you were going to approach it again
because there was this affection for the
original, the w did, it's sustained,
that people would be
incredibly disappointed if
you just went back for it for
that reason.
So it was kind of risky.
Commercially it's obvious
to go back to it. Um,
but actually in truth it was very,
very,
it's very risky unless you
had something personal,
some real powerful reason to make it
like we had for the first time we were,
we approached the book,
which nobody wanted us to do because
people couldn't see how it could be called
Boma film and the kind of type of people
it was about was where, where would,
where would not be attractive
on film, UN, UN, UN, UN, UN, uh,
more than that,
that would be unacceptable really.
But we had a passion for that and you
have to find that passion in the new
version. Otherwise you'll, you'll, you'll
just end up disappointing people and, um,
and then they will crucify you.
And rightly so because you kind of
gone back to something that has,
has a value in their life that you're
lucky to have that place, you know,
so it was,
it was age really.
And um,
for all of us involved,
for me and the screenwriter
initially John who,
who had himself a bit
of a medical emergency,
I don't know if you've seen the film
of any, have you seen it yet? No. Well,
does it kind of like,
you'll see it as a kind of like,
so I know what to give away and not one,
not to give away. Anyway, there was,
he'd had a kind of medical emergency which
gave him a bit of a crisis and that's
the focus part of the film is what
triggers the re-ignition of their time
together and the, their friendship
again. Um, and then it was really,
it was weird doing it because
the film is really you really part of
making the film was realizing what the
first film was about,
which we didn't really know
cause everybody said it's
a drug film. And we said,
no, it's not. It's a film about
friendship and things like that.
But actually the first film is a study of
energy and you thought, or you boyhood,
if you like,
is a better way of putting it.
And this is actually about the transition
and how badly man make it to manhood
really is sort of what it's about really.
And uh,
and we learned while making it home much,
although winning get terrible
flack for age and time,
actually women age much better than
men way, but men are terrible at it.
They just,
we hang onto the past in a way that's
actually eventually embarrassing and you
don't realize it. Um, and you'll see that
in the film really. And it's one of the,
and it's,
it's one of the things that makes the
film attracts it because they do try and
we live in the past. That's not
just a commercial reason to do it.
They literally do try and the effort
was Bravard or the past is kind of saw
attractive to them. And there's a
couple of seasons where they do that,
but actually it's inappropriate.
No, in a way. And, and anyway,
on women age and much, much faster. And
they're all women in the film who, um,
they don't have a huge amount to do, but
what they do, they do devastatingly well,
really. I'm like, Oh God,
yeah.
Women,
women have always been sort of a catalyst
for the characters in this for me at
least as a viewer, I'm like, okay,
well there, you know, part of yeah.
Of what has driven them,
these guys to do these things.
And it was interesting because both Diane
and Gail's characters are back in this,
it's the whole cast is back. Yeah. Um,
but was there ever a point
where you guys were like,
actually we might explore and we do see
more of that with like big beast family,
but were you ever considering putting more
of the female perspective in or is it,
I mean, obviously the first one is so
much about like these, this guy dynamic.
Yeah.
Yes. It is a, and it was
um, it was, I mean we did,
when we set up the film, the, the
key questions that people asked is,
would the four guys that come back
again to be at the center of the film,
would it be the same actors?
And, but the second question,
people always ask these would Kelly
McDonald comeback to play Diane?
And she does. And uh, and but we
had another scene for her later.
So she did have a bigger part to play and
we caught it because it diminished her.
And it's weird the way film works.
It doesn't work.
Like it is almost script
at all and it's slightly,
it was better that she just
has this one central scene,
which he does beautifully and UN
and it's devastating nuclear war.
How much more successfully she's dealt
with time then the Renton has dealt with
time. Um, and uh, so we actually,
if anything in editing,
we reduced it. Really,
their agency is very important in the,
in the film, but it is quiet. Yes.
And, and that's not to say there
aren't strong female characters in it,
but it was, it was interesting because
they were returning, um, uh, you know,
family and father son dynamics are also
a big part of this. Again, as a viewer,
at least I felt. And I'm
curious like, you know,
in the first one it is all about youth
and questionable moral decisions,
but adding a family layer
definitely sort of changes that.
Were you at all afraid that it would
adjust like the tone or was it just like,
no,
this is actually the way,
the best way to display some of
these evolutions of these characters?
Yeah, there's a whole bunch of kids
running around all the way through it.
Some of them are, uh, kind of from,
some of them are images of themselves
as children. Some of them are, are,
are there children who are
very disappointed in their
fathers and some of whom
are imaginary children in one
of the characters cases. Um, um,
and I know obviously it's kind of from,
from a commercial point of view that's
very unattractive because everybody wants
to believe still that there,
like they were in the first film
where they were running around in this
completely care careless world.
But it's,
it's honest about really
where they are and it,
and it was quite interesting that the
four actors all became fathers after that
film. Um, the original film,
they weren't fathers when we made that
film and they've all become fathers. No.
So it is very much a, uh, like you
said, it's a look at fatherhood in,
in different relationships
with their own children and,
and also with their own fathers in a way.
There's a couple of key scenes
about their own fathers as well.
So that dynamics very
important to it as well,
which doesn't make it sound very
attractive. It makes it turn rather of,
I can hear it as I'm saying
it, you think, oh my God,
what have they done to train spotting?
But actually it's really,
there's an honesty in it that's
really essential to it really.
And you and you have to find this balance.
When you do a sequel like this,
there's an extraordinary balance
you have to find between,
everybody wants it the same but different.
And it's that kind of
thing where it's got to be,
it's got to have these trigger points,
these kind of muscle
memories of the first film.
But also to have any honesty it's got
to be different because they're 46, no,
you know, not 25. Um, so it's
the difference in that really.
Um, one, uh,
one of the things with that is like there
is a good deal of humor in this, right?
It's not like a dark, like we're
making it sound very dark and dramatic,
but there were like
there's a ton of humor,
but how do you balance like those moments
and how do you make sure that humor is
something that's universal because
there was also a lot of, you know,
a lot of it does have to do the UK
culture and the source material,
but how do you manage that ship?
Like
you can't really think like that really.
Cause that's very much
a studio perspective.
How can we make sure this humor applies
everywhere and it's deadly. I think,
you know, I mean it's not in terms
of Pixar and things like that,
you know they do it brilliantly,
but in terms of the stuff I do,
it would be deadly if you started to
worry about how's that going to play.
Especially with characters
like this because again,
the first thing you do is start
reducing their accents so they were more
comprehensible,
which would be incredibly on truthful
to them as characters because they're
there. Their accents is, it
identifies them in a way.
It's a kind of defiant pride in
in how local their culture is,
you know, verbally anyway,
and the linguistics that's
in urban while she's books.
I like that the book is a challenge to
you from the get goal as soon as you open
it, it's like that's a
challenge and can I do it?
And obviously as the way we know
with accents it they unlock.
If your patient,
they unlock very quickly for you,
but you can't compromise that upfront,
which it would be the tendency to do to
make it more palatable or to make sure
that it traveled. Really, you
just hope that it will do that.
People will see things in it that they
recognize across cultures, I guess.
I guess aging is a universal
thing across cultures,
whether or not we want it to be. It is,
it's in the post for all of us. So it's,
it will be there even though you don't
like acknowledging it sometimes. Um,
but yeah, it's there
for everyone. President,
whether you're president or whether
you're homeless, it's the same applies.
If you could go back 21 years and tell
yourself one thing about where either
your journey or where this film's
journey was going to take you,
would you take the opportunity and if so,
what would you tell yourself? Oh my God,
that's like those letters that people
write to themselves as younger people.
My God,
I don't know what I'd say really.
I've been very lucky really with
the stuff I've done. I mean,
I think I'd probably put more time
in with my kids. Really. I haven't,
because I've been out doing stuff like
this and making films and stuff like that.
So I suppose I'd say look out for that
a bit more really. Cause the kind of,
you can't repeat it back again, but us
as terribly depressing thoughts really.
Um, yeah. Enjoy culture, really.
That, so that's, that's the,
that's the most important thing.
I think it's weird.
We were just talking about this before
about, um, someone said, um, what,
so Renton in the film,
I was a terrible crisis.
His relationship in Amsterdam
was broken down and that's what,
and what's one of the things that
drives him back and he has nothing.
The relationship has broken down. She's
taken the hose that they were living in.
He has these kind of, well I won't tell
you, but uh, cause that will spoil it.
But he's in crisis about,
and this guy says to me,
what would you say to a
guy like that who's 46?
He has a line in the film where he says,
I'm 46 and I'm fucked.
And what would you say to a guy like that?
And I was trying to think,
what would you say someone like that
and I all you would say is reach for
culture really.
Cause it can save you in a way that I,
I've learned over time.
Um, and, and when, and the,
and the future that we all face know with
jobs becoming more Ramal or becoming,
you know,
um,
not being there anymore
because of Robert's ization
or mechanization or you just
reached for culture, you know,
it'll save you in the end.
That's my own personal philosophy. You
know, it's like, I think you know, you,
why do you read, you read that.
That's what they say, isn't that you,
when you read a novel,
you read to know you're not alone.
That's why we read weirdly,
it's a solitary occupation.
But actually you read to know you're not
alone because you recognize things and
w and that written the
reach of culture is,
and I know it's a terrible
time at the moment because,
and it certainly is in Britain a way,
culture is just sneer that and
kind of disparaged and it's an end.
It's not about politics,
culture,
it's actually about something much
more important than everyday politics.
It's actually about something deep
that connects people across cultures,
across their individual
cultures and across time.
I think it'd be fair to say
that the world as a whole,
including like the UK and the
US have changed dramatically.
Like politically since you
guys even film the film, right?
Like forget since the first one.
But since the production of this film,
we've had a lot of changes
but our horse Brexit,
but is there any part of the film that
took on sort of an additional context for
you because of the time that
it was getting released now?
Well, date, they come in and out of
focus. Weirdly, I remember we, we, we, we,
we shot the, we shot 28 days later. Um,
w when we, this a horror movie that we
made, we kind of butt and when we shot it,
the idea of the film was that it was
about social rage because there've been a
number of instances,
which you hear about it occasionally,
but there'd been a particular number of
instances in Britain of people literally
having arguments in,
in,
in traffic jams and getting out
and stabbing each other, you know,
that kind of incredible intolerant
rage of each other that was happening.
So that was our philosophy for
the film. That was like, wow,
we'll make a film about social rage.
And the thing that drives these zombies
was actually a kind of thing tolerance
of each other. And that was
our philosophy and everything.
We set it to make the film. We shot
the opening in London in the summer,
you know what he's wondering,
run London on his own and it's empty.
And then we started shooting the main
body of the film in nine 11 happened and
the film came home and the film was
not about social rage, it was a boat,
the vulnerability of cities.
It was weird about, and it was,
and it was an a think in
the film was a hit here.
And I absolutely know that
was the reason because it was,
it was the first film out with a block
that dad look up the terror of feeling
incredibly vulnerable in these amazing
cities. We build free for ourselves.
And you can't predict that, you know, you
just, there's no way you'll know that.
So sometimes they swim in
and out of focus really.
And you can't say what there'll be,
they take so long to make the bone not
to be applicable to daily politics.
I mean, otherwise you'd make
documentaries and make them very,
very quickly and get them out. Like
John Lennon used to say, you read,
sing the song in the morning and have it
on the streets in the afternoon. But um,
otherwise they're never
going to be up to date.
But you do read things into them for sure.
And um,
I don't know what you'd reading to this
one about Brexit and about Trump or
anything like that.
I just don't know.
Maybe people will see things in them
that has some kind of resonance on that
level,
spoil anything.
I feel like just because there were
a couple of months where I was like,
oh okay that's,
that's something that,
I don't know if that was
the filmmaker's intention,
but it for me where I live and you know,
the climate I live in that had a different
meaning that I think it might have
originally,
well we were shooting,
we were shooting when the Brexit
vote happened and there is a kind of,
there's a plot elements in it to do with
the European Union, but we kind of get,
we couldn't get her hedge run them
or ramifications of it. So we,
we just shot it anyway.
And it,
and it's in the film as a as
it is at the moment though,
we still don't know what will actually
happen with Britain and Europe fully.
Although it looks like Brexit will
happen. Yeah. And if it does happen,
Scotland will almost certainly go.
That seems very clear cause,
well although we were shooting there
at the time and it wasn't, it was an,
it was a vote to leave the European Union.
Uh,
Scotland voted 62% to stay in.
So Scotland will break away from the
United Kingdom and stay in Europe.
The Scots don't like the English anyway.
They never have done,
not since 17 or seven when
they were bonded together.
So the opportunity to finally get
away from them, they, they'll,
they'll palliate to the French. What's
more than the English anyway, the Scots,
they are always known for that.
That's called the old alliance,
the relationship of Scotland and France.
It is interesting how like the
first film just took on this,
like it became this purely Scott like
a Scottish thing, right? It's, it's,
is it interesting for you not being
Scottish first of all to be at the helm of
that and to see the second one
given that timing come out,
like reignite that sort of like, yeah.
Scotland pry like and you're like,
am I going to be responsible for this?
It is interesting working in Scotland.
I, I did enjoy it. They are tough.
They don't suffer fools gladly.
There's no kind of Hollywood welcome
of kind of light, you know, um,
and you and you and you have to earn your
right to be there really to work there.
Especially in film terms. I felt that
very strongly in making the first film.
And I'm, I'm not, I'm not a nor what
I claim to be an honorary Scott,
I'm far to a county to ever say that.
My background is,
I actually Irish,
I come from Manchester,
return in the northwest or an industrial
town in the northwest of England and uh,
my heritage is all Irish really.
So maybe that was why they accepted me,
you know. Anyway, we did W it's Joanie
that he deploys to more than anything.
I say Johnny Lee Miller, who's one of
the four guys, cause he's not Scottish.
And um, when we made the
first film, he adapted,
he did that method thing where he just
adapted the Scottish accent in his daily
life as well.
And I remember Kelly MacDonald who with,
she was really upset when we
stop filming because he, he,
they were,
we were having a party afterwards and
he was talking and he's natural accent.
She was really upset that he'd lied
to her all the way through, you know,
and she was really genuinely very upset
about it. She still talks about it.
Didn't know cause she'd been completely
taken in by him. Um, as a, as an, as a,
as a a fake Scott really.
So that's like the highest
compliment is an actor.
I assume I was like got a doctor,
but you still have to deal with her upset
you and you and Johnny work together.
It like super recently to write on
Frankenstein Frankenstein. Yes, yes.
Yeah.
Is it,
is it sort of interesting shifting mediums
like that and like coming back to not
only film with him but something that,
you know,
he and the rest of the cast had
been with so long ago? Yes. Yes. It
was extraordinary.
Like,
what are the key jobs as a director of
a large part of your job as a director
with actors is that they're often very,
eh,
they're like on eggshells at
the beginning. They bit careful,
a bit wary of doing too,
too soon until they find their feet and,
and understand what the
process is and how that,
how close they are to the
character and stuff like that.
And part of your job as a
director is to encourage them, um,
over that chasm of confidence
really to get them to step forward.
Especially because I quite
like big performances.
I'm not a kind of mumble core
kind of salt, social realist,
kind of just do nothing with the lines,
just let the camera do everything.
I quite like performance. Um,
but on this it was the opposite.
They had that built in to them cause they,
they'd obviously been in the first movie,
it had done very well for everyone and
they personally felt absolutely in charge
of that character and they were very
clear about what that character would and
wouldn't do.
You know they had a,
they knew him even though they hadn't
done him for 20 years. So that was weird.
They,
they um,
you had to step up as a crew and as
a director you have to lift yourself
straight away cause they were,
they were at 100% straight away,
which is unusual on a film.
You know normally your
pussyfooting around for
the first few days really.
And you can often see that in a film,
which is obviously done out of order,
but you can often see the
films that aren't quite,
and they're often the first days of
filming where people are not sure of what,
what they're doing. But there was none
of that. No, they were fully ready to go.
What was the first thing
you guys feel forward?
The foreseen we thought first thing.
So when people watch it again,
there's a scene under a pub with Begbie
comes back and see sick boy for the
first time.
Is that,
so that's the Robert Carlisle character
and the Johnny Lee Miller character.
And they got under the seller of the pub
and, and the, where there is adult farm,
cause he's doing a bit of cultivating
on the quiet sick boy and they have this
discussion about taking
revenge or Renton together.
And you'll see that's
the first scene we shot.
And the crew was shocked at how big
the scene wall straight away like,
um, and we all had to
lift our game from there.
Know, speaking of drugs. Um,
so again,
the world has changed a great deal since
and I don't know of heroin and heroin
use,
even drug use aside from maybe like the
fight over here at least over like is
should marijuana be legal? Like I feel
like it has taken sort of a back seat.
And you guys do address a little bit
about like the other ways people distract
ourselves if it's digital, if
it's, you know, running. Um, but,
but was there ever a temptation to
sort of update more of the story to be
involved more of these like
other distractions that
people are more engaged in?
No, the, I mean there is a
big speech about it. Um, he,
he does have a choose life speech,
which is because of an update really
have is what was quite a famous speech
about, you know, the choices that society
offers and eat. There is an update.
I think you guys are mentioned
in its one point. Yep.
That's probably,
again,
it's one of those objective viewer
things where you're like, um,
all the different choices that
are available, social media, no,
et cetera along like that. But actually
the speech is really about, it's,
it's actually a confession
in the end that um,
he hasn't made good choices really it
becomes a confession by the end of it.
Um, no, I, and I think like
the drug use thing there,
there are some drugs in
the film, but again, it's
appropriate to 46 year old guys.
So there's a lot more viagara
in the film. Then there is, um,
some of the other drugs of choice in
the, in, in the first film. So in fact,
Begbie takes so much Viagra.
At one point, he medically,
his heart would explode, but it doesn't
fortunately for the film. But um, you,
you have to see that to see what
happens. What does it explode? Yeah.
Is that the type of thing you have
to do research and before like, okay,
he can take this many people.
Well then you get an Edison cope
together and taking lots of Viagra pills.
So it's eight s fake. It's not
fake by I grew, but it's um,
Viagara from China rather than correct.
[inaudible] street.
[inaudible] street via
ground. Um, so what do you,
what do you think the role of
failure is?
Because these are characters who failed
time and time again and they keep going.
And I don't know, like I, I'm sure we all
are. We're humans. We experienced failure,
right? And it's, it's either
internalized and like, Hey,
I think this is a failure when
really it's people could be like,
this is a smashing success.
So what do you think like that role
plays either in the characters,
in film making in life?
The film is as characters,
they are failures,
absolute failures.
I mean in the first film,
the only success in the first film is
that he steals the money off his friends,
which is, can hardly be looked
at as trial color. Um, so it's,
it's saturated with failure really.
But film is odd and especially film
that has a sense of humor and a kind of
independence of spirit.
It doesn't come across like that does it?
You don't think when you leave the other
film, Wow. Their failures aren't they?
If anything, you kind of like
think they're cool, you're
rooting for them. Yeah.
But he's like morally reprehensible,
but also they were attractive as well,
even though they are morally reprehensible
and it carries on into this film as
well, I think is that, you know,
they're not until spot or something
right at the end of the film,
which is truly transformational in a
way that you'd never expected on thing.
What they amount to his failures,
you know? Um, but again,
film has that weird thing of elevating
people and it's why we cut the duck.
The scene we were talking about earlier
about this Diane scene that we caught.
We caught it because it made her
ironically made her look like a failure.
No matter how we played it or cut it,
it made her look like a failure,
which is completely wrong,
you know?
And yet that's because
you're following Renton,
you're emotionally empathizing with
rents and really with presumably without
fully understanding the crisis is in,
you know,
it is very film does mythologize people.
And it was one of the
interesting things about,
about doing this film and explained it
to the actors before we started that we
were going to unlock that image people
had of them in the first film because
film is extraordinary. It
is. Film is time, isn't it?
When you edit film, it's all you're doing
is extending time or compressing it.
That's what you do with editing.
It's just that the whole time.
And you have this additional
power where you can freeze time.
And I think we do that in
movies. We have, uh, you know,
especially our favorite movies.
We have an image, you know,
a mind of an actor in a path like
boomer Thurman in pulp fiction,
you just have an Emmy
or John Travolta report,
you just have an image of them
when you just freeze it in time.
And I said to the actors, that was one of
the things we were going to try and do.
It was on lock that, that, that,
that frozen moment with them. Um,
which would be very cruel on them
and it is very cruel, you know,
when you see them in the, in the
way you remember them, the skinny,
cool guy who smears everything and here's
the update right next to each other
like that, you know. Um,
and it is extraordinary like that
film that it can do that, um, as an,
as an art form it.
But I don't think there is another art
form that gets at this anywhere close to
having that connection with
time like film does, you know,
how do you achieve something like that?
Do you talking about that,
like that particular scene where you're
bringing back basically the ghosts of
the versions of them passed. Like, do you
have someone on set? Who's the standing?
Do you show them that scene beforehand?
Do you wait and not show them
that scene until afterwards?
Some of it was still enough towards,
I had warned them that
we were going to do it,
but it's done afterwards in a in
effect. I mean you used tricks, you,
you can have stunned ins too.
We cast a lot of young guys who
look like them in the first film,
including one young guy who'd
been tormented throughout
his school life because
he looked just like you and McGregor
in trainspotting and he'd grown up with
this. Everybody teased him about
it and finally got his own bike.
He got to be Ewan Mcgregor. And that
was bizarre. You and seeing him,
you know,
for the first time we ever met him,
cause he was dressed as you and walls
in the first film and then you meet this
kind of doppelganger like, um, what's the
great kids? Lawsky Phil is a great kiss.
Lawsky filled the boat. The double double
life of Veranique is a wonderful film.
Um, you get to meet you. That's
what they say, isn't there?
There's a double of you
somewhere in the world out there.
There is an absolute double if you do.
But statistically I think that's true,
isn't it?
Kind of the number of statistical chances
of there being someone there is there
will be somebody out there who you would,
if you met them they would be,
it would be like meeting a mirror anyway.
That was weird for the axiom that you use.
Sometimes you use a double,
sometimes you use footage
from the original film. Um,
yeah, we, we didn't use it.
They've changed so much.
You can't use them as they're on the
stand ins at all under any circumstances,
you know, cause they really do look,
it is very honest about the film,
about what they look like. No. Okay.
Uh, did you experience it all like a sense
of Deja Vu because you shot in some of
the same places?
Obviously you're dealing with the same
characters and actors or was it like,
nope,
this is just a new experience?
The, the, the, the most acute moment
was when we went to [inaudible],
which was this countryside place in the
first film as if a speech where he says
it's shite being Scottish and they go
out to the countryside for 10 minutes and
they hate it, you know, and they decided
to go back and take drugs instead.
There is a new scene out there again and
we went out there and it is obviously
exactly the same until the moments in,
of course these people passing in front
of it or like a fly just moving across
it later.
But that's 20 years to the moment.
And it's just like a movement like that
that brings you down to earth. Yeah.
Ce Mark.
So that's a kind of put and it is a very,
very important moment in
the film where they, um,
there was a reckoning moment there
really where they, uh, some of Tommy who,
who did, he went out to the
countryside with who died of
his, uh, his addiction. Um,
there's a reckoning about that in the
film as well. Yeah. At that moment,
I would like to know who inspires you
as a director. As a director? Yeah.
Where's the human? But mostly as
a director it's like different.
I like that young. I did you, did
you see don't breathe horror movie.
I thought it was so I remember watching
that as it director. You watch some time,
do you think arc?
You know,
he could really direct like I
thought that was really good. Um,
what's he called? Fetty? [inaudible].
Alvaraz is, I think he's called.
I remember thinking that. So sorry. That's
just jealousy. That's not inspiring.
Um, no, I, I, I'm one of your low, I mean,
coupler is one of my big,
huge inspirations, you know,
and not just as a, from everything
I've read about it. I mean,
I met him once actually, I was like,
it's terrible. Meeting your heroes.
I was Jelly, absolute jelly. I mean,
I'm a grown man and I was just
shaking meeting Francis Ford Coppola,
who's just like, who doesn't really
care, but everybody's like that with him,
I think. Um, so that was quite special.
But everything I read about him, um,
also confirms what special person is and
I think he's work is certainly from one
particular period is as good
as it gets. Really. You know,
that's a big thing for me and another
British director who's also a very,
very fine mum is very and very elderly.
No Nicholas Roeg there they're
big inspirations for me.
But on a personal directing level,
yeah.
Do you find it challenging
watching other people's work? Um,
like do you or do you find that you're
able to disconnect or is it watching it
and just being like, oh, I want to do
that. And why did he get to do that first?
I'm very good and very good at shit
unless it's terrible when you do start to
take it apart and I don't
take stuff apart at all.
I kind of get lost in it
and kind of cry and um,
it molts and shouting dog breathe.
I was shouting,
there were like 20 of us in the audience
in London watching it in this cinema in
Stratford just, and we were shouting
and screaming at the, you know,
which you don't hear a lot in England.
It's kind,
you do get that a bit more here
in cinemas here. I like that.
When an audience is a molt like
that start show 10 but you don't,
everybody sits in a respectful silence
in England. Um, but uh, yeah, no,
I'm more like, I, so I don't
take it apart. No, I didn't.
I tend to get lost in it.
Really. I was, I'm very
grateful. I do really. And um,
especially on planes,
I was reading it,
but someone saying why
we cry on planes g I,
I do cry at movies more on planes.
The non earth.
I've heard, I'm not kidding. I've
heard it's like the elevation.
Something about that that makes the
tear ducts Ron Moore, the pressure,
the pressure to do with pressure.
Keira Knightley movie and I'm crying.
He's like, wait, they said no,
but could be wanting to be a Rockstar,
but I'm crying anyway.
Um, so you've covered a lot of Sigmadek
grounds since the first one. Uh,
you've gotten to the slums of India,
the canyons of Utah.
You've got to silicon valley,
a fracking site, lab space. Uh,
what's something you've haven't
done yet that you would like to
musical? Oh, really? Oh yeah, no,
that is, I think for any director.
Um,
that's the one that's the grail,
the holy grail that you'll, you'll,
you'll probably never get to.
And if you do get to,
it probably won't work,
but I'm a modern,
um,
original musical is virtually
impossible to pull off. You know,
obviously there's been more
very recently that did work,
but the [inaudible] to get
your characters to sing,
to actually just start moment of singing.
That's the kind of terror moment.
Can you do that? Um, so I,
I still trying to do that in a way
it's going to say there's very good key
musical moment in this film that was
like fascinating to watch him,
just to give them,
they're like the stakes of
the circumstances. They were
in a good scene. Yeah. Um,
so, so a little bit, you can
do it a little bit of singing,
a little bit of singing,
your move isn't a bit of dancing
and all that kind of stuff. So, um,
but it's the original concept. But we,
we, we did a kids film called millions,
which is a lovely little
film about two boys.
You find a sack of money and
it changes their lives. And um,
and that was originally meant
to be a musical and we were,
we had this idea that we
get Noel Gallagher to write
the songs for these kids
because it was sat in Manchester
where no comes from as well.
And we kind of check into away from it.
You need a lot of
confidence to pull it off.
And we were just seem to lack it in
that moment and we made it as a straight
film and it's a lovely film. I'm
very proud of it. But um, yeah,
it should have been a musical cause those
kids could have saying then you'd have
never questioned why they were singing
or you'd have loved them singing,
you know.
Anyway,
I mean there is this sort of
trend of like taking films,
adapting them for the stage and then
putting them back as a musical film,
maybe millions musical. Oh, I said, okay,
I'm going to take that as a no.
Are there any genres that
you like don't necessarily
have like an inherent
interest in directing,
like westerns or animated films or is
it everything just like the world's your
oyster? I tried to do
an animated film, uh,
an adaptation of a Terry Pratchett
book called the Barometer Yard.
There's your first problem,
Terry Pratchett. It's so
hard to, yes, very difficult,
but God bless him. And
um, and we would, we,
me and the writer of the millions
scripts actually frank cultural voice,
we set it up at dreamworks and we were
warned all the time about how long it was
going to take.
And uh,
and we backed out of it in the end cause
it really was you, it's all very well.
Somebody saying seven more years,
seven years like that to you and you just
kind of go, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you got closer and you
realize it is going to be seven years.
And so we backed off it as well. It's
a lovely scratch. There's a little bit,
I don't know whether it'll ever
see the light of day. So, um,
so I think my last question is,
uh,
what's just one thing you'd like
people to take away from this stuff?
You have to distill it down.
I think it's the, it's what,
so as we did the film does it kind of,
one of the weird,
one of the weird things about
getting older, the one of the,
the few compensations about
getting older is the um,
um,
I said Kingsley Amos said that the only
conversation we're getting older is that
at least you know what's
funny and what isn't.
I don't know whether that's true or not,
but one of the few conversations
phoned about age is that you,
you have this weird recognition
that time is not a straight line,
that there's a kind of
loop in it somewhere.
And there is a section of the film and
it's to do with spot at the end of the
film.
And he begins to recognize his voice,
which in the original movie and an India
original stories of what's in his whole
plus character,
utterly chaotic and hapless
and nothing ever goes for him.
He's the ultimate addicts in a way,
on and off and on and off and on.
It's somehow he's just to survive.
But he finds his voice really.
And I think that something that I
believe in personally very deeply,
and it's a new Irving's work,
is that no matter how impossible it seems
for that person to have an important
voice,
every voice is important.
And that seems impossible
thing to impossibly platitude
in his thing to say in
the modern world where life
is so complicated. But if
you lose sight of that,
you're lost. I think, you know,
because you have to believe that all those
[inaudible] and it's just how they'll
find the value in their
voice that's all in.
And he finds the value in his voice
and it leads to a loop where you,
you start sort of experiencing
the first film again, um, in,
in the second film, and they loop back
on each other. And, uh, I love that.
I don't know whether people
will get that from the movie,
but they'll probably just have a good
time watching you and Greg and make a fool
of himself or, you know,
stuff like that. But, um,
that's very important to me
in the film. Yeah. Cool. Well,
thank you so much for joining
us today. Cool. Thank you.
That's fine. It was a good, good time.